hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica yes it is
time to get back into the ocean of which
there are new da new this is a whole new
game basically it's kind of builds on
the premise of before it's not exactly a
expansion pack because it's a separate
game whatever it's a lot of premise for
a lot it it's more subnautica but this
time is cold I mean that's about it so
expect it to be a bit more polished than
the last time
some notic was first released as an
early access thing this is a new early
access version of the game the game is
not gonna be fully released for a long
time
subnautica is done this is a year after
the events of subnautica after the
escape I don't even know if this is the
same planet and frankly I wouldn't be
surprised if it was the same planet but
the fact that they're back on the same
planet after the [ __ ] that went down and
almost killed the entire galaxy from the
virus yeah I'm thinking that maybe it
might be a bit of a dangerous thing to
come back here but we're here and that's
all that matters same corporation same
technology but different person probably
maybe I don't know alright MP good to
know you're back wait no you're not back
you died I know you died
this is nice it feels pretty good
whoo Wow is this what a nice base looks
like because to be perfectly honest I'm
not put old I can't like it I can handle
me no I wanted to snooze that oh my god
Pat's 1.1 stop the crack alright anyway
was the excellent thank you
thank you Robin good all Altera
application review okay all right
why have you applied for this role
everyone's talking about four or five or
six B who hasn't applied maybe Jeffries
no Jeffries signed on last week why this
assignment the last time we found
sentient alien knife was straighter 617
years ago it's been fun but frankly I'm
bored and you have a telepathic squid do
you know how I talked to them I think
you correlate responses against stimuli
and I do what they do if they bathe in a
liquid nitrogen and talk with their feet
I put on a coat and I pull a handstand
but this recruitment process it's most
alien of all so I'm trying to correlate
my responses here I want us to
understand each other put me on that
planet I'll talk with the fish for you
thank you miss Goodall Sandra Sandra
Sandra will show you out Sandra yeah
okay apparently Robins a little
overeager okay
boring we are different but we go
together okay so expect it to be the
basic template of the same game is that
me is that me I'm beautiful
let me hope that's me they're cute but
I'm beautiful
oh my god I'm pretty hello okay so it
looks like the same planet because these
are definitely the same creatures and
that's definitely the same plans I don't
know what the hell you are but I like
you
hello okay hello sit nice man this is
what it looks like when someone actually
cares about whoa that is a big boy
that's a big boy that's a big boy okay
all right who's this kiddie audio I
guess uh-huh oh my god okay you're just
putting me to shame because this is way
better than it oh my god are you kidding
me with this ridiculous remember
information leading to the activation of
alien technologies rewarded with
automatic rights buyout and the $10,000
credit
research of cultural of historic value
is not included in the bonus scheme
buyout still applies
great ok cool here I go baby I'm going
for it wow wow wow wow that's actually
pretty cool ok that's pretty cool I like
that look at my hands ok I'll check it
out understood
you know the form of it's cute but we've
shared a room would it kill your career
to act like we've met before I don't
care who knows it's cute I've been here
two weeks we've had Lee spoken because
he went straight to the planet find
Jeffries chat later yes mom
uh-huh okay so we're twin sisters
apparently alright that makes sense
where's Sam I saw snowman over here I'm
on a gum we'll give it a look
also I've got a voice which is not what
happened in life you're cute I like you
goodbye oh yeah what have I done
whatever I can't Crouch I'm over it okay
I'm over it umm what's over here will I
break my legs if I do this oh my life I
don't care about that here we go okay no
animation for that but that's fine early
access my legs are moderately snapped um
yeah okay let's just follow the trail
I'm done exploring the environment oh my
god oh oh no I'm okay you're freaking
space heater your stovetop I don't your
give me some of you you are a space
you're a space I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
not taking this very seriously but you
are a space heater that is hilarious
really funny okay all right you were Oh
hate it okay I was about to say you were
creepy
you guys are creepy oh good gracious
okay guys well that's that's ten types
if not okay all right
Sam or not Sam Who am I looking for
Roger who I remember you Billy Jeffrey I
think it was Jeffrey hey Jeffrey why are
you being such an [ __ ]
why can't you be back at the base did
you die whoa Oh weird ice okay right
Jeffrey are you dead because of the
aliens did the aliens make you dad is
that a coffee machine that's a coffee
machine oh hey how you doing coffee box
can i okay never mind
all right how do you know my name I come
in peace Sam the building just powered
up it spoke to me
Annie right I'm fine
no sign of Jefferies oh hello
all right during their occupation of
four or five four six feet of a serious
race of spacefaring aliens we refer to
as the Almanac selected the number of
sites around the planet to which to
build their vast facilities while the
folks saw their mission to say they're
kind of from the bacterium was the
Emperor specimen contained at the
primary containment facility there are
other installations served a variety of
precautionary and support roles white
while zero sector contains a number of
now familiar alien sanctuaries the alien
facility in close proximity to the main
research station remains one of the few
whose purpose we have yet to discover
this will be the focus of our endeavors
in the z-row sector well we know frozen
bodies since ice undreds of years ago
the facility lays dormant to this day we
have progressed only through the first
four field gaining access to the
antechamber where a combination lock of
a type we don't understand prevents
further
we're racing whatever's inside is
protected more thoroughly than anything
else we have encountered all right maybe
that's for a reason maybe we shouldn't
go in there met five five five no all
right an unknown mechanism the lock is
so mysterious with its weird alien
symbols they look like a an S an S an SN
a backwards s a big circle I don't get
it there's a line weird symbols
oh whoa my space heaters oh no that's
not good I think all right well hey
buddy keep me warm in this in this side
place am i I guess I'll go back I guess
I'll go back do i oh I go up here okay
that that makes a lot more sense okay
hello hi I'm gonna die would anybody
like to get my [ __ ] oh wow oh that's
weird
it's beautiful for being an early access
they've really done a good job about
this so far this opening sequence is
quite nice well made learn some lessons
from the last game I guess and they made
a little more polished right off the bat
which is nice and I appreciate that
where am I going exactly oh my god okay
I'm going back to the pace all right
cool I feel like when they finish this
off it's war is um what the hell I feel
like there should have been a bit more
fanfare all right so okay I guess I'm
going down I'm yelling timber oh [ __ ] I
hate it I hate it
get me out get out oh god I hate it
I don't want to be an illusion ah all
right I thought there was solid ground
there for a second I just didn't like
being thrust into it all of a sudden I'm
okay with going in the ocean I want
everyone to know that I am okay with
going in the ocean I just wasn't ready
to go right now
all right here we go there's a reason
all right I just don't like going
exposure in four minutes oh okay all
right I just don't like the idea of
going down into undersea caves that I
don't know where they are
the original subnautica I played it
enough that I knew where everything was
but the problem with this game is that I
don't know
what's lurking around the coroners so
the idea of swimming in an undersea cave
it's just really hard for me so give me
a second huh okay um happy do come in uh
emergency mode okay cool great all right
I'm okay just everyone give me a second
to be a big [ __ ] and I'll be fine
that's pretty that's also horrible
because it's like Tripta phobia I hate
that cuz you know you know oh what is
dad oh I can't keep sayin what's bad
what is that
Oh what is that Oh replenished from did
I just suck that in did I suck did I
just give that up
hey suck that oxygen now okay all right
good great
okay this is my nightmare on the way
back from Cincinnati we drove by one of
the deepest lakes in in America we were
driving through like Oklahoma if for
some reason in Oklahoma there's a really
deep lake and even Amy's talking about
the idea of swimming in there was really
bad for me so oh my god like it's my
nightmare oh [ __ ] here we go oh my god
here we are
oh that's horrible
oh my god oh my god that's gonna kill me
I just I'm a lightning rod in the middle
of the ocean I'm gonna die okay all
right well I'm here I'm out an open
water yeah I am a rescue shuttle no I'm
okay I just need shelter fine I'm
sending a temporary habitat instead look
up I'm looking up thank you Sam call me
when you get there Oh Oh like an escape
pod it's it's like pop G they're gonna
make a battle royale version of this I'm
getting an airdrop hell yeah I can't
wait to get a rocket launcher out of
that bad boy really blow of some
leviathans okay all right oh wait are
those oh hang on before I get anything
oh my god
because you know that they're gonna have
new leviathans in this game you know
that they're gonna have new scary things
you know that they're gonna make frozen
terrors from the deep I want you in my
hand give me you I've got a bladder fish
I feel comfortable because this feels
like feels like something I can control
am i swimming am i swim huh am i
swimming I think can I not climb up on
these apparently not okay
I saw you Pangos I saw you I saw you
Pangu all right you can go you can go
goodbye all right have fun oh wow hi
Hey how are you can I grab you I hate oh
my god
oh my god that's cute you're horrible Oh
ah you're the worst are you cute you
cute little baby why are you walking
around on your dick Oh
bata is a beautiful thing hey moon hello
oh hello oh wow that's beautiful
oh it's beautiful hey it's look it looks
like the the the the wallpaper that
never actually had anything that was in
the game in it but now it does because
that's beautiful
oh there it is okay okay all right okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
I don't like those tentacle looking
things okay all right we're fine why is
this have to be underwater why I'm home
baby
Sam I'm at the habitats I'm home anyway
I don't Jefferies nothing yet and the
facility it's that my name I need to
know why I know it makes something to
eat get equipped I have answers by then
we'll do make something to by that you
mean catch fish and eat them cuz I don't
have anything so I just I'll just do
anything fiber mesh silicon rubber glass
copper wire battery I'm just checking to
make sure things are relatively the same
cooked bladder fish cured bladder fish
always good standard o2 tank fins
first-aid kit
scanner flashlight survival knife air
bladder air bladder that's new sticker
just duct tape a couple bladder fits
together suck in and suck out at liberal
use it doesn't hurt the bladder fish in
fact they like it you should probably be
more concerned that they like it
alright here we go all right you all
right you you you you you you you
all right I got this is that a peeper oh
it's a peeper it's a fancy peeper I
can't get you I need fit what wait what
just ate that I hear oh hi thank ya okay
I got you it's my trap if I just don't
move they're never good for me it's as
simple as that
how what did I use that from the other
side okay that's a hack all right
eat away I've got cold and spongy great
that sounds wonderful
I like the sound of that these are some
good eats let me tell you all right
get in my belly yum yum yum nom nom nom
oh yeah okay I'm all right I'm all right
guys yes I swear I just I just I see
shapes of things in the darkness and
they look like monsters and I'm not okay
with it
I'm just trying to get my bearings guys
all
oh my god it's so pretty look at how
pretty that is it's so pretty my god
it's beautiful
I hate everything under it but it's
beautiful god I'm sorry I'm just
oh [ __ ] I just don't like it okay I need
to start harvesting things I'm not gonna
go in the deep because I don't want to
what is this is this a sea Glide do I
need to scan that okay I probably new
scan or get that which means I need
titanium to be able I heard I just heard
something that I didn't know I heard so
let me get this first you douche get
copper that's probably not what I need
to do what is that oh that's nice okay
it's gonna be like the same it's gonna
be the same I know it's gonna be the
same general basic premise of monsters
cuz it's the same it's it's the same
it's just still the same and I know that
and I understand that and I'll bite the
head off of this fish if I have to to
survive I would do a lot just to survive
so don't test me I will mess you up I
don't know what that is what is this a
ball soccer ball grab trap Oh grab trap
okay sure yeah I'm in the deep end
though I don't like being in the deep
end I don't want to be in the deep end I
don't want to be I don't want to be in
the deep end I just don't wanna be give
me you guys
i I I need to make an air tank and fins
first and foremost there but I need a
knife too okay I need the basic
equipment it's just gonna be a bit of a
challenge for me to get the balls to do
the basic [ __ ] but give me a second I
think I'm getting better because now
that I'm seeing their fraud they
wouldn't put they just wouldn't put
deadly monsters in the starter area they
don't it's the safe shallows that's
that's what it is it's the safe it's the
safe shallows that's just what it is so
I would be safe in the safe shallows now
they might they might not keep it safe
that is a thing that they could do they
might but they also might not so there's
that I'm okay thank you is that a die is
that an eyeball
that's an eyeball that is that not an
eyeball oh no oh oh no
it's the Hooper it's still uber what did
you oh you're a Penghu oh I see oh my
god are you deadly can I swim
thank you for killing those I think
those were deadly they were red which
they remind me of the other fish that
were awfully bitey I will not apologize
for being cautious
it is the only thing that's gonna keep
me alive in the face of the unknown is
being cautious I do not like the
insinuation that this is not a dangerous
situation because it is I just hate the
ocean it's just full of death like
that's the thing the ocean is just full
of death there's there's death happening
right over there when those fish are
being eaten by the pang goose the that's
just death that could be me when there's
something bigger coming along and you
know that in this game they're gonna
make it bigger whoa okay all right hey
how you doing hi are you doing you're
cute you're real cute you guys are cute
but I need this blood come here you come
here sexy come here okay that's bigger
than I remember she said hey oh it's a
baby still got a dick I don't not good
hello hello can I grab you oh you all
have dicks ah that's not that's not
that's not that's not a Pangu where am I
where's my bass a little too far out for
bass oh I'm a little too far out for me
so just I'm gonna go back i I've got
what I need so I just need to swing back
and alright I've got enough to get
started I probably don't have everything
that I need but I got enough to get
started and what is that is that a mini
Leviathan it's huge I mean it's kind of
big Oh what are you are you bad please
tell me you're not bad are you bad you
bad you're not bad you're cute okay
you're cute okay I thought you were
dangerous you're cute you're cute okay
you're cute you're fine it's the safe
Alice one of my craziest to say it's the
safe shallows of course it's a safe
shallows safe is right in the name
of course is the safe shallows it's safe
area okay okay this is going
surprisingly well let's keep these guys
in the fish tank until I need them let's
do that I've got titanium I've got
quartz I've got copper this is going
well
basic materials class do I need glass I
don't need glass ribbon plan what do I
get that ploy Able's waterproof Locker
[Music]
why okay so I need silicone rubber which
I think I need oh my god it's gonna
dynamic weather system I think that's
really cool but it's a very scary
I don't like random booms happening and
apparently the clouds don't work when
you're underwater oh that's okay you
don't need them probably just to save
loading time okay so I kelp kelp
probably is in a dangerous part
it's fine it's fine I'm fine it's fine
I'm fine
this is fun I'm fine this is fine I need
I need like either kelp or what was that
oh I don't know what that was but it
sounded bad I know oxygen I get it
I get the whole premise oh no oh no I
forgot that there was night in this game
okay that's fine
what is that I don't know I don't care
um in there uh in like the caves there's
probably I think I saw little bulbous
vine things hmm why why here yeah here
okay I saw these vine things are these
okay these are okay these are plants
that I can pick okay they only take one
that's good okay so I need to find these
I just didn't know that they were pick
up a bowl okay good all right so it's
night but that's fine it's not really
any darker than it was before you're
cute you're less cute at night but
you're cute stop so I just got to find
more caves that oh that looks poopy it's
real poopy I just gotta find more kick
it's so dark it's so dark
oh my god it's so dark and so dark my my
I forget sometimes that the whole see
glide had a flashlight built into it it
didn't make it better but it also made
it so that I could actually run away
from things which I can't now cuz I'm
not fast enough I don't even have fins I
don't even have fins aren't even a fins
I don't even if it I can't find oh my
god I can't see in front of my face it's
beautiful there's beautiful brilliant
beautiful but I can't see well that
looks good I think I need that I don't
know why it's red not yellow where it
was before
give me give me me okay a my fault I'm
full okay let's just go back let's just
go back that's all I really need it's
all I really needed anyway these
blood-red whatever have you I got you
what I'm cold I lost all my gear and I'm
no wiser to what's going on but I'm
alive another drop hold on there's an
emergency cash hasn't been touched since
the scouts landed six months ago could
be useful tell me the cords on your hard
no no no no no no no no no no no no I
don't know whatever it doesn't matter
oh you can eat those cold resistance
that's nice okay let me just see if I
can make like an oxygen tank or can oh
the storage those stupid
okay um fibermesh creepvine silicone
rubber okay silicone rubber is good
because I think you need that to make
the knife which you need to cut the vine
to get the other things that you need
okay you need fiber mesh and I need
silicone rubber do I have enough for
another yes I do I can at least get fins
so going faster will make me feel a
little bit better I don't want to go
there but it's telling me to go there so
go there is what I'll do I'm gonna go
there I'm a sign it's the one I'm gonna
go what did I get the ribbon plants for
I don't even know well whatever it
doesn't matter I'm just gonna go there I
don't know why I'd need any of this but
I'm gonna go all right here we go oh my
god
ah okay it's fine it's 300 meters away
that's actually not that far so it
should be fine
it should be fine that's not far enough
to go into a different biome in the
meantime I'm gonna slice me off some of
this yeah how much did that take okay -
all right now that's gonna spoil I
forgot about that I'll get it on the way
back then okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay
where am I
I can't see Oh what is that
okay it's fine I think it's fine oh
there's big holes but that's fine hello
high-capacity o2 tank that's helpful
because I'm about to die I'm about to
die can I please oh god oh god oh god oh
god ah okay I'm fine I'm fine okay god
I'm sorry I'm a big [ __ ] but I'm
getting used to it there's nothing in
here that can hurt me so long as I
remember that Frick you're so big
you're so big you're so big and so clear
what
okay so I can make a high-capacity
oxygen tank now which is great I love
that that's so cool I haven't made a low
capacity oxygen tank that yet but I can
make a high capacity oxygen tank so
that's cool so I'm gonna do that last
titanium is silver or so I don't even
have silver or so I'm just gonna make
the standard one until I can get silver
or because I don't know where to get
that right now
Pathfinder did a fish just kill itself
on my habitat screw this not being able
to see anything [ __ ] because I'm I'm
kind of over that kind of just a lot of
over that okay floating air pump that's
interesting I don't care I've never used
that before I'd I don't know I need that
now I got I got by with it without it
before I don't think I'm gonna need it
now I don't need a beacon I've never
done that ever so I don't even need that
I don't even need to do that cuz it's
just not important
okay there's a day it's day okay it's
day it's day so I'm gonna go back to
that at least I have a knife and I've
got a scanner I can start scanning
things so that's cool there we go
pin a card I can scan the sea glide
where'd the seagull I go I can do that
there's a peek in or grab thing or
whatever have you I need another sea
glide frag Bend but that's okay I need
two more okay that's fine
so it's day and I've got a flashlight so
I should be able to yeah shine it in
your eye that's that's the way to go
about things
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay you you you you
okay you're fine I still don't know what
hurt me I don't think it was the big
thing I think there must have been like
a small fish that I didn't see that was
like the small red guys I think those
are actually dangerous
maybe not deadly but dangerous why is
there a nipple pokin out of that I don't
know I don't care
scanning no no I can't have more
underground tunnels in my life please
tell me this has silver or something
like that
silver outcrop oh I guess it doesn't
have silver in it oddly enough
who'da thunk silver outcrop no silver I
would have thought but apparently no
apparently big no on that one
I like quartz quartz quartz quartz I
like for salt salt I don't have salt
salts good babe oh that's the thing okay
that's the thing that's it's tiny
I could probably kill it with my knife I
could probably fight you why am I scared
of you I could fight you easily go away
let me just go for this I don't know
what I missed out on but apparently I
missed out on something hello I made it
here there anything whoa what is that
precursor technology okay whoa thirty
Seconds
all right let me go break these nothing
in there nothing in here nothing in here
nothing nothing
I don't need gold I need silver oh I'm
gonna die how about die oh my god I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I am an idiot and I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die oh
my god I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
not dead okay I'm fine okay okay
I just need some silver there we go
that's what I'm talking about baby
daddies what I am referring to this is
what I am talking about this is exactly
what I didn't want it bloodroot what
route what route Oh
oh no I hate it oh I hate it oh where am
I
generic bull ah generic bull
of course of course of course I should
have known I should have recognized it
from it's obvious distinct features very
generic if ever there was generis ISM
the good news is I think I was just
being an [ __ ] and scaring myself and
that's good news because that means that
there aren't heightened whole fish oh
yeah there are whole fish yeah hey hey
hey back off I'm not scared of you
anymore
did you just get killed were you just
killed
give me my Austin I sucked it right out
of you I sucked you dry
I sucked and now you're gonna now you're
gonna drown you stupid fish yeah I'm the
superior creature because I don't do
that
yeah this is good I I think I get I go
through weird moods in this game where I
get I like get scared
for obvious reasons because this game is
terrifying but also like I get over it
and then I realize it's really pretty
they happen to coincidentally coincide
with the day/night cycle it's usually my
wonder terrified feelings about this
game and that's not my fault that's just
a factor of how the game is so like it's
not my fault is what I'm saying hey give
me your I'm gonna suck you I'll give me
a straw baby yeah
I will readily admit this is beautiful
like what's great about them making an
expansion game or a like a sequel
whatever you want to call this a
successor game is they've already
learned all of their mistakes they've
already had all their polish they've
already got like all the base level game
figured out from before what is that
what is that what is that oh that's no
that's an oxygen sucker
I can slurp oxygen right out of that Oh
I don't know where I am I don't know
where I am I don't know where I am I
don't know what the boom was about hey
okay I think I'm fine I need to find
another glider parts oh there we go
and I think that's the last one okay
bada bing bada boom that means I can get
myself oh there's another one I guess
they were all around the base oh yeah I
should have realized that they were
actually just kind of surrounding me
they made it really convenient and I
didn't actually do enough and that's not
sitting on the ground there but that's
okay I'm gonna forgive that okay okay
good this is good this is shockingly
it's good I think um yeah I think it's
going well so what I can make now is the
high-capacity tank the bada bing bada
boom and that is nice that the oxygen
tank doesn't take up space like that
real nice about that oh okay good 96 100
that's great okay that's good that's
really good wiring kid that's probably
important um for what I don't know I
guess I could make nothing I can make a
whole lot of nothing see glide I need
Lube do I have enough for Lube yes I can
make Lube
I can make Lube see the thing is like
now I'm fine now I'm fine it just takes
me a little bit to get used to the
unknown like that's all I'm afraid of is
the fear of the unknown that's it like
it's not it's not that I'm afraid of
like it's not that like I'm just too
much of a [ __ ] baby it's that that like
I don't know what's out there and I
still don't
so like it's gonna be like this the
farther out I go but once I get the
whole game under my belt then I'm not
gonna be scared anymore
alright drink my own piss I can't do
that yet I can't do that anymore I don't
have the piss suit so I don't have the
piss suit so I can't drink my own piss
ha alright but it's fine because I can
make a battery and if I make a battery
then I can make the seagull ID and I'm
gonna need a lot of batteries to keep
the seagull I going I bet I bet but I
have myself a see glide which means oh
yeah I can run away like a big [ __ ]
baby yes ok so this is as good a place
to end it as any thank you everybody so
much for watching I'm just gonna look
out the window at the safety of my own
thing it's night and that sucks
but thank you everybody so much for
watching sub Nautica is back which means
that we've got a whole world to explore
and I'm gonna do it it is the thing I'm
gonna do it and it's gonna be great and
I'm really happy about it and I'm gonna
do it so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]